c'était prince les chimères de l'exil un
formidable film réalisé par Thierry
Leclerc qui nous fait l'honneur de
participer à Z la Zone d'Éducation
documentaire bonjour à vos côtés nous
accueillons clair Rodier bonjour vous
êtes juriste au gisty le groupe
d'informations et de soutien des
immigrés et cofondatrices du réseau
migrent merci infiniment à vous deux
d'avoir accepté notre invitation enfin
surtout elle invitation des élèves du
lycée Théodore Aubanel à Avignon bonjour
les élèves
alors je sais je sais que vous avez
beaucoup travaillé sur ce documentaire
vous avez plein de questions mais c'est
moi qui vais commencer par vous en poser
quelques unes d'abord quelles sont
quelles sont vos impressions qu'est-ce
que vous avez pensé de ce documentaire
quand vous l'avez vu la première fois
dites moi pour moi c'est un documentaire
qui est très touchant parce que en plus
il évoque un problème que nous en Europe
comme on vit en vivant ici on n'a pas ce
problème on se pose pas ce genre de
questions et de voir le genre de
questions que peuvent se poser des
enfants qui vivent en Afrique ou
n'importe quoi permet de de faire ouvrir
les yeux à beaucoup de personnes qui
vivent dans les pays comme la France et
que on a beaucoup de chance de vivre ici
est-ce qu'il y a des séquences des
images qui vous ont particulièrement
marqué qui vous ont choqués dans ce
documentaire oui lorsqu'on a vu les
élèves à l'école disait la seule chose à
laquelle il pensait c'était parti et
c'était pas comme nous ici on pourrait
penser par exemple qu'est-ce qu'on fait
après l'école quelle activité on fait en
sort ou alors que eux leur seul souci
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour s'enfuir
comment pourrait-on faire je pense que
en tant qu'Européen on n'a pas trop ces
questions à se poser parce que on a on a
un cas de vie confortable on a enfin
beaucoup ont une famille on a tous une
maison et on n'a pas du tout la même
misère que que les autres africains ont
que dans d'autres pays en fait
défavorisés ont donc mais après on peut
toujours se poser la question de a
est-ce que ça pourrait être moi qu'on
veut toujours avoir plus c'est qu'en
Europe c'est un peu le rêve américain ou
le rêve de ce qu'il y a au dessus
mais pas au même niveau prince en tout
cas évidemment est-ce que ça vous
viendrait à l'idée vous aujourd'hui là
de partir pour aller dans un autre pays
oui mais peut-être pas dans les mêmes
conditions est-ce que tu crois
aujourd'hui toi de ta place ici depuis
le lycée Aubanel qu'il existe un pays où
tu aurais plus de chance de réussir
non non
le fait d'avoir vu ce reportage ça nous
fait réaliser que toutes les
toutes les petites choses dont on se
plaint au quotidien ben ça a pas de
valeur en fait au niveau de
Prince bien sûr et bien on va passer à
vos questions et on commence avec toi
Kia pourquoi avoir choisi ce sujet et
est-ce histoire de prince qui vous a
alerté ou est-ce la multiplication de
ces drames
alors c'est une bonne question moi je
travaille depuis des années en fait
comme reporter alors je travaille des
fois pour la presse écrite souvent pour
la télévision et je suis depuis quelques
années sur les routes de la migration en
Afrique de l'Ouest au Maghreb en Europe
et pour ces reportages ou pour quelques
fois travailler avec des journalistes
des journalistes africains des
journalistes maghrébins et on réfléchit
ensemble à comment mieux parler de tout
ça et il se trouve que j'étais en Côte
d'Ivoire au moment où j'apprends ce
drame malheureusement des drames comme
ça il y en a pas mal mais c'est vrai que
ça m'a particulièrement touché vous
savez en reportage écrit vous restez
c'est formidable c'est fort vous restez
quelques jours puis vous repartez en
documentaire vous allez revenir
plusieurs fois vous allez créer des
liens donc j'ai créé des liens avec la
famille de Laurent Barthélemy de Prince
quand il voit qu'on revient deuxième
fois ah oui là c'est pas le journaliste
éclair qui qui vient et qui repart ça
l'intéresse donc je voulais montrer en
un mot
cette question de migratoire qui depuis
des années maintenant il a une des
médias comment elle était vécue
profondément dans une société de départ
on appelle ça des pays de départ hymen
pourquoi avoir choisi ce titre pour
votre documentaire assez vite j'ai vu
que dans la famille Laurent Barthélemy
on l'appelle sur Barthélemy mais son
surnom était venu prince parce que sa
mère trouvait que il avait l'irradiait
comme ça il avait cet innocence aussi et
pourquoi les chimères de l'exil oui
chimères sur leur écran il voit les
mêmes choses que vous ils ont le nez sur
la vitrine on dit la vitrine de
l'Occident avant c'était lointain on
savait qu'il fallait faire 8 heures
d'avion mais aujourd'hui c'est très
concret et voudrais s'habiller comme
vous il voudrait mettre les mêmes choses
sur il voudrait
ils ont peut-être une vision alors
idéalisée
vous savez il y a une chanson cette
chanson d'Ismaël Isaac que vous entendez
dans le film qui dit plutôt mourir en
mer que la honte devant ma mère sans
arrêt on entend le discours sur la mer
on fait ce projet très compliqué et ça
concerne quand même peu de personnes en
pensant aussi à sa famille on part pas
pour soit tout seul et alors vous claire
Rodier comment vous l'avez perçu reçu ce
documentaire
il est à la fois très touchant très
prenant pour l'histoire de Prince
tout ce à quoi ça renvoie
moi j'ai des enfants voilà donc bien sûr
on pense à ça et puis et puis à tout ce
que ça traduit de la réalité en fait de
cette phénomène qui est la migration
tous ces gens qui sont obligés de partir
pour des raisons
la plupart du temps tout à fait normal
tout à fait audible pour des raisons que
je comprends et qui sont entravés dans
leur route il y a beaucoup d'injustices
qui sort du film il y a l'injustice que
ressent le père de Prince et puis il y a
l'injustice fondamentale que certains
peuvent bouger et d'autres n'ont pas le
droit de bouger d'autres sont assignés
chez eux et c'est ce qui se passe pour
un très très grand nombre de de
gens qui vivent en Afrique dans la
plupart des pays africains et pas
seulement monter dans un train
d'atterrissage c'est pas parce qu'on n'a
pas l'argent de prendre l'avion c'est
parce qu'on n'a pas le droit de prendre
l'avion c'est pas seulement parce qu'on
n'a pas l'argent c'est ça qu'il faut
voir aussi dans cette dans cette
histoire on poursuit avec toi Alice
avez-vous coupé des scènes au montage
c'est à dire des scènes que vous ne
souhaitiez pas montrer oui alors je
pense que j'ai dû tourner
enfin 25 heures peut-être donc vous
imaginez il faut un récit il faut savoir
sur quelle personnage on va se centrer
la sélection elle se fait assez
naturellement mais c'est un long travail
on dit qu'on écrit trois fois un
documentaire c'est dans l'écrit une
première fois vous savez on écrit un
projet voilà je voudrais parler de
Prince Laurent Barthélemy son histoire
ensuite il y a une deuxième forme
d'écriture au moment du tournage parce
qu'il se passe toujours des choses
inattendues et c'est ça qui est
formidable et puis il y a une troisième
écriture quand on a ramené toutes ces
images et que là réellement fait le film
et le film est quelquefois assez
différent de celui qu'on avait imaginé
au début
Eglantine a-t-il été facile de trouver
des témoignages et est-ce que les
Ivoiriens étaient prêts à parler face à
la caméra alors la majorité presque tous
les Ivoiriens et ivoiriennes étaient
prêts à parler la difficulté c'était
plus les autorités et je vais vous faire
une confidence j'ai finalement
déposer des demandes d'autorisation mais
vous voyez je les attends encore
j'attends encore les les réponses
Nicolas comment votre documentaire
est-il été reçu par la famille de Prince
et plus communément par les
Ivoiriens ça a été très bien perçu par
le Père par les enfants il y a Grace la
soeur qui me touche beaucoup et je crois
qu'ils ont été ils étaient dans une ils
sont toujours mais il était encore plus
à l'époque dans une profonde détresse au
moment de l'enterrement j'étais le seul
blanc
et je crois que ça les a marqué
c'est un réseau de d'associations et de
chercheurs et moi maintenant j'apporte
mon expérience de militante puisque je
travaille dans une association française
de défense des droits des migrants et
aussi un peu de de
documentation et d'informations et ce
qui est important pour le réseau c'est
de montrer que les politiques qui
organisent la mobilité des gens
les politiques migratoires qui sont
décidées par les gouvernements en Europe
aussi beaucoup par l'Union européenne
ont des conséquences directes de qui
vont consister à violer en fait les les
droits des personnes et le réseau Migros
il a surtout travaillé au début sur les
questions des frontières et de
l'enfermement des migrants parce qu'il y
a énormément de gens qui sont enfermés
dans des camps de rétention ou toutes
sortes de noms un peu partout en Europe
et mais aussi
dans d'autres pays que l'Europe
simplement parce que ils ont voulu un
moment donné quitter leur pays et aller
dans un autre pays et qu'ils avaient pas
les papiers qu'il faut pour ça non
t’écoute quel est le profil des migrants
existe-t-il d'ailleurs un profil il y a
pas de profil type des migrants ce que
les recherches ont amené à réaliser il y
a déjà maintenant pas mal d'années c'est
que contrairement à l'image qu'on a
peut-être nous en Europe quand on quand
on pense aux migrants c'est qu'il y a
plus de 50% de femmes en fait dans les
migrants c'est-à-dire que plus de 50%
des migrants c'est des migrantes ça va
magasin pour Monsieur Leclerc donc
quelles sont les raisons qui poussent
les migrants à partir
alors déjà une petite précision quand on
parle migrants peut-être que dans notre
imaginaire on pense tout de suite à la
migration irrégulière à la Méditerranée
au froid je m'attention les migrants il
y a 290 millions de migrants dans le
monde il y en a une toute petite partie
qui est la migration irrégulière c'est à
dire sans papier comme Laurent
Barthélemy donc faut bien savoir de quoi
on parle donc pourquoi il partent ils
peuvent partir parce que leur pays est
en guerre et là ça va donner des
réfugiés qui vont demander l'asile ça
peut être pour des raisons on dit
économiques oui on peut appeler ça aussi
une migration de travail on va chercher
du travail alors vous savez qu'en
général on va chercher du travail
d'abord dans les pays autour de chez soi
une majorité pour les Africains et une
minorité va aller en Europe pas du tout
s'imaginer que l'Afrique va se déverser
en Europe ça on nous le fait croire
c'est absolument faux ce qui a de
d'intéressant c'est que les raisons que
dont tu as parlé Thierry partir pour
travailler travailler partir pour
étudier voilà ça peut ça peut vous
concerner aussi mais dans votre cas on
appellera pas ça migrants on vous
appellera pas migrants on appelle les
Français qui vont à l'étranger pour
travailler on les appelle des expatriés
voilà c'est la réalité toute la
différence entre
la mondialisation des hommes c'est le
nouveau rapport de la planète des hommes
à la planète c'est les mobilités
internationales donc on a un peu
diabolisé ou focalisé sur certains
migrants mais c'est tout simplement
aujourd'hui comment on habite comment on
parcourt comment on se déplace sur cette
planète quel est le parcours des
migrants c'est-à-dire quelles sont les
différents pays traversés et dans
quelles conditions si on parle des
routes de la migration donc irréguliers
j'ai pas de papier
j'ai pas de billets d'avion et je vais
partir de l'Afrique de l'Ouest bah j'ai
plusieurs possibilités je peux prendre
le parcours qui me fait traverser le
Sahara m'amène au Maroc me fait
traverser
[Musique]
avec ce pays qui va conduire l'Europe je
dirais à faire feu tout bois pour
obtenir que les gens restent du côté
libyen c'est un phénomène qui s'est
développé particulièrement avec ce pays
parce que justement cette configuration
pas vraiment d'état des mafias locales
favoriser la comment on pourrait dire la
montée des enchères sur ce que c'est que
ce que ça représente que le trafic des
personnes qui veulent migrer mais ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que
ces gens ne peuvent mener ce commerce ne
peuvent trafiquer que grâce à la
fermeture absolue des frontières qui est
décidée par les États donc c'est
vraiment une responsabilité voilà
prendre le passeur comme responsable
c'est de voir qu'un tout petit bout du
problème le passeur le trafiquant il ne
fonde son activité que sur les interdits
voilà il y a ça va du très très gros
trafiquant au tout petit passeur qui
n'est finalement qu'un migrant lui-même
et je voudrais dire aussi que dans le
passé dans l'histoire le terme de
passeurs il a servi aussi à désigner les
gens qui ont sauvé des Juifs qui
cherchaient à passer en Espagne voilà
c'était des passeurs aussi des gens qui
passent sur des résistants qui voulaient
passer en Angleterre
voilà donc il faut faire attention à
cette notion là c'est évident qu'il y a
des très très gros trafics mais pasteur
c'est pas juste un mot pour rejeter sur
désigner un méchant Aurélien la peur de
la mort pousse-t-elle certains à
renoncer vous l'avez entendu ça sur la
peur de la mort bien sûr mais ce qui
surprend plutôt quand on discute avec
beaucoup de jeunes c'est au contraire
leur bravoure leur courage c'est pour ça
que vous savez quand des migrants
arrivent sur la terre européenne en
Italie en Grèce en France mais il
faudrait pour moi presque leur donner
une médaille et en tout cas pour ceux
qui sont passés absolument les
accueillir et les accueillir dans de
bonnes conditions parce qu'ils ont passé
des épreuves tellement incroyables et
tellement terrible les récits à n'en
plus finir son dramatique qu'on devrait
avoir le devoir moral de de bien les
accueillir on a vu la tant mieux pour
les Ukrainiens on voit qu'on accueille
dans de très bonnes conditions les
Ukrainiens c'est formidable mais ça veut
dire dites donc à bah finalement il y en
avait des logements ah bah finalement on
n'était obligé de bloquer les migrants
là sur les terrains vagues et de leur
donner même à peine de l'eau et des
moyens il y en a s'il y en a pour les
Ukrainiens ce qui est à nouveau
formidable qui en est aussi pour les
Afghans pour les Soudanais pour les
Ivoiriens vous la ressentez cette
distinction ouais qu'est-ce que vous
vous dites sur justement sur l'accueil
des
Ukrainiens ce que vous avez cette même
sensation oui chérie j'ai l'impression
qu'il y a c'est un peu difficile à dire
comme ça mais que l'accueil des migrants
il a été beaucoup plus favorisé que
enfin des migrants Ukrainiens du coup
que des migrants qui proviennent
d'Afrique on les a accueillis à bras
ouverts on l'a tout fait pour les aider
et c'est tant mieux et c'est tant mieux
mais
il y a d'autres migrants qui étaient là
avant et qui sont toujours dans des
conditions
qui sont pas vivables malgré la crise en
Ukraine c'est quelque chose que vous
avez saisi oui je vous vois tous réagir
pas vraiment à comprendre c'est comment
on peut
traiter différemment des personnes qui
fut exactement la même chose juste pas
des mêmes pays enfin quand on voit qu'à
Calais il y a certains camps qui ont été
démantelés de migrants pour en
accueillir d'autres c'est un décalage
que personnellement j'arrive pas à
comprendre c'est à dire qu'il y a cette
loi de la proximité qu'on comprend bien
oui l'Ukrainien on voit comment il vit
il est plus proche de nous c'est normal
c'est normal qu'il y a une empathie plus
naturelle mais nous notre boulot c'est
de donner un visage à leur embarquer les
MI au papa de Laurent Barthélemy de vous
faire comprendre que le deuil qu'il
ressent est le même que un deuil que
ressentirait un papa français et c'est
cet effort de proximité mettre des noms
des visages des histoires qui pour moi
est une de nos principales tâches pour
que l'Ivoirien vous paraisse aussi
proche que l'Ukrainien
on poursuit avec Jade
pour avoir des
des précisions sur le cas des femmes qui
tentent cette aventure et les risques
supplémentaires qu'elle court
c'est sûr que par définition presque les
femmes courent plus de risques que que
les hommes
statistiquesment et quand je parlais
tout à l'heure de femmes qui arrivent
avec des bébés parce que des bébés sont
nés pendant la pendant la route si une
jeune femme
veut venir de Côte d'Ivoire jusqu'en
France ça peut lui prendre un an parce
que au cours de cette année elle va être
elle peut se trouver bloquée rater
séquestrer et parfois violée pendant
cette période là et il y a des pas mal
de naissance qui viennent dans la
migration à la suite de viol et de ces
vis parce que voilà ça c'est vraiment
les risques de la migration on entend
une jeune ivoirienne dans le film dire
que enfin c'est son père qui dit Dieu
merci
il ne lui a rien à arriver je ne sais
pas si c'est la jeune fille qui l'a
rassuré
à une vieille collectif tout un c'est
comme si elles sont victimes ma première
prière c'était que elle ne tombe pas
dans la main des violets Cyril comment
les migrants qui ont réussi à trouver un
pays d'accueil sont-ils perçus par leur
pays d'origine
reprenons le cas de l'Afrique de l'Ouest
c'est assez étonnant de voir que au Mali
au Sénégal en Côte d'Ivoire on parle
finalement peu des diasporas on parle
peu des
nationaux qui sont partis
travailler mais ils sont souvent assez
bien vu pour quelles raisons c'est parce
qu'il rapporte de la richesse et que ce
qu'on appelle le PIB vous le savez c'est
à dire que une part importante enfin une
part de ce PIB ça peut aller jusqu'à 6%
pour le Maroc vient des Marocains de
l'étranger donc c'est diaspora sont
souvent bien vécus par les pays
d'origine qui savent que c'est très
important et que ça nourrit beaucoup de
familles
quels moyens les pays d'origine
mettent-ils en place pour limiter ses
départs et éviter les drames
en fait tous les pays d'origine n'ont
pas forcément les mêmes pratiques et
parfois ils le font
plutôt pour faire plaisir à l'Europe
pour avoir l'air de coopérer à ce que
demande l'Europe parce qu'il y a des
rapports de dépendance économique
politique géopolitique mais il y a pas
forcément des moyens énormes qui sont
investis quand ils sont les moyens
énormes financiers en général c'est pas
les pays d'Afrique ni de Maghreb qui les
mettent c'est l'Europe et bon les pays
suivent plus ou moins avec plus ou moins
d'enthousiasme mais c'est pas leur
problème principal
comment l'immigration clandestine
a-t-elle évolué depuis ces dernières
années et comment l'expliquer vous moi
je dis plutôt immigration irrégulière
que clandestine parce que finalement
c'est une clandestinité qui est très
contrainte comment elle a évolué ils ont
qu'au cours des dernières années on a eu
une grosse vague d'immigration de de
migration
de de personnes qu'on a appelé plutôt
réfugiés qui venait de essentiellement
de Siri mais pas tout à fait seulement
en 2015 jusqu'à 2016 mais en réalité
sinon en Europe on compte la migration
irrégulière uniquement
elle tourne autour de 150
000 personnes par an qui arrivent sur le
territoire européen et ça c'est à peu
près constant en fait depuis 2000 grosso
modo sauf ce pic de 2015 qui s'explique
par plein de raisons et notamment la
guerre civile en Syrie
Malak j'avais une question pour retirer
Leclerc pourquoi malgré tous ces drames
le rêve d'Europe existe-t-il toujours
le rêve d'Europe il est irrépressible
j'évoquais ces jeunes qui sont sur leur
écran d'ordinateur et qui voit
votre vie se disent pourquoi pas moi et
ça c'est tu peux pas tu peux pas
l'empêcher il y a eu ce monde c'est
rapproché
et finalement à votre âge on peut voilà
estimer qu'il y a une vie mondiale qu'on
pourrait qu'on pourrait partager et des
besoins et des envies qui sont communes
donc ce besoin là il ne changera pas ce
qui devrait changer c'est notre manière
de voir est-ce que nous les riches entre
guillemets ce qu'on doit monter les murs
et ce qu'on doit se protéger et ce qu'on
doit réfléchir différemment en disant
non c'est plutôt un monde de circulation
organisons cette circulation ou c'est un
manque de fermeture et on va monter les
murs je pense que aucun mur ne résiste
on peut toujours passer dessus en
dessous je crois pas trop au mur
ça va quelles sont les chances de
réussite dans les pays d'accueil et
qu'est-ce que la réussite et ben ils
sont très grands c'est une chance de
réussite parce que il y a presque une
sélection naturelle ce sont des jeunes
donc en majorité des hommes même si il y
a plus en plus de femmes qui ont une
niaque incroyable qui ont passé ces
épreuves qui ont un profil de caractère
puisque à nouveau tout le monde ne part
pas donc quand on arrive dans ces
conditions-là au bout du chemin au bout
de la route et bien on n'est pas là pour
comme on dit toucher les allocations
sociales et tout on est là pour bosser
on est là pour travailler on accepte
souvent n'importe quel travail et donc
il y a beaucoup beaucoup de migrants qui
trouvent très rapidement du travail je
dirais regarder dans les cuisines des
restaurants regarder sur les chantiers
de travaux publics donc
quand les migrants arrivent ils trouvent
assez facilement du travail vous parliez
tirer le clair de cette niaque
incroyable ça me rappelle cette scène du
film vous l'avez vu aussi ces jeunes qui
sont en tenue de foot
je suis prêt à tout affronter même si
c'est pour mettre ma vie en jeu je suis
prêt pour le faire moi moi je suis prêt
à prendre le riz
faut aller faire sortir ma famille de la
misère parce que là-bas il y a beaucoup
d'argent qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé
de cette scène c'est logique qui pense
comme ça et qui réagissent comme ça
puisque vu qu'il n'a rien il a son
sentiment de recherche il a envie de
rechercher ce qu'il n'a pas et on le
voit bien même dans ses yeux on voit
bien qu'il a envie d'avoir ce que ce que
nous on a aujourd'hui et c'est triste à
voir d'un côté parce que
on sent qu'il la manque et que tous ces
jeunes qui sont rassemblés ont tous un
manque que je trouve triste c'est que
j'ai l'impression que c'est jeune il
croit pas en leur pays et parce qu'en
fait même quand on regarde
au tout début je crois que c'est le
directeur de l'école il leur dit vous
pouvez très bien avoir un master ici
mais en fait ce qu'ils pensent c'est
comme il y a pas d'argent dans leur pays
ils pensent qu'ils peuvent pas réussir
et ça on peut pas les empêcher de penser
comme ça mais du coup
c'est dommage est-ce que tu te sens
privilégié ah oui oui je me sens
vraiment privilégiée même ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure aussi qu'il y a
certaines personnes qui n'ont même pas
le droit en fait de prendre l'avion
quand vous dites ça je me dis mais
comment c'est possible
enfin nous c'est un droit qu'on qui
paraît normal pour nous alors que eux
ils ont même pas la liberté de faire ça
et cette notion de liberté qu'est-ce que
vous en avez pensé à travers ce à
travers ce que vous avez vu à travers le
le parcours de Prince oui ça va
obliger de partir pour être libre il se
à mon avis emprisonné en fait dans leur
pays d'un côté je pense que c'est aussi
une des raisons qu'il est pousse à
partir
très juste sur la contradiction entre le
discours je voulais mettre ça en avant
du proviseur qui du mieux rester ici
travailler bien vous aurez un avenir bah
non c'est pas comme ça quand tu dis il y
a pas d'argent si il faut vous
compreniez que la Côte d'Ivoire
spécialement est un pays riche
qui n'est ou la richesse est comme dans
beaucoup de pays très inégalement
réparti il y a de l'argent c'est mais le
problème aussi c'est que bah oui on va
pas demander à ces jeunes de dire me
battez-vous exigez des droits renverser
le gouvernement
j'ai envie de bâtir mon avenir et mon
diplôme qui me sert à rien donc le
discours du professeur qui est qui est
beau quelque part mais il est pas
efficient parce que on sait bien que ça
marche pas comme ça et c'est avec mon
bac dans ce lycée j'aurais pas grand
chose
que je voulais demander quels sont les
pays qui accueillent dignement du coup
ces migrants et comment la France elle
se situe par rapport à ça si on regarde
l'Europe la France a pas une très bonne
place en fait dans le dans la dans
l'échelle ni en quantité de personnes
accueillies ni en qualité
si on peut donner des notes vous vous
souvenez peut-être qu'en 2015 pendant
cette fameuse période qu'on appelle la
crise des réfugiés
l'Allemagne avec Angela Merkel avait dit
bah on va ouvrir les frontières là il y
a plein de gens qui sont assez en Grèce
qui arrivent de Turquie qui arrive par
la mer
il faut les accueillir voilà Angela
Merkel avait dit ça et pendant quelques
semaines les frontières ont été ouvertes
et voilà un million 1 million tous de ce
chiffre ont été accueillis en Allemagne
parce que si on sensibilisés plus les
personnes qui vivent par exemple en
France
à ce genre de problème est-ce que ça
paraîtrait pas plus normal d'accueillir
toutes ces personnes moi je pense que ce
type de documentaire
joue son rôle il y a d'autres choses qui
qui faut faire mais ça joue un rôle pour
expliquer
pour expliquer ce que c'est voilà comme
vous vous dites bah voilà on comprend
petit à petit des choses l'autre chose
moi qui m'a paru efficace je l'ai
constaté c'est quand on est directement
confronté à une situation voilà on voit
parlons encore des migrants qui sont
dans la rue ça fait c'est sale ça fait
un peu peur c'est un peu bizarre en plus
il parle pas la langue et mais quand
j'ai constaté que à chaque fois que des
gens s'approchent discutent un peu
essaye de discuter propose un truc à
manger voilà reviennent le lendemain
vois qu'il est toujours là finalement il
se voilà il se posent des questions et
et ils arrêtent d'être enfermés dans
leur propre raisonnement c'est la
distance en fait qui c'est l'impression
qu'on est loin qui piquerait la peur
voir l'hostilité l'eau à nous t'écoute
j'ai une question monsieur Leclerc donc
vous interviewez les acteurs dans le
documentaire je suis la misère
la misère morale
là-bas j'aurais je pourrais dire ce que
je veux et comme je veux attends c'est
pour ça seulement que tu vas là-bas mais
pourquoi tu ne vas pas dans une de nos
forêts ou si une de nos montagnes sacré
tu pourras crier comme tu veux personne
ne te dérange pas
ce qu'il n'y a pas de démocratie chez
nous et ça tu ne pourras pas me
l'enlever de la tête selon vous quel
rôle la culture pourrait-elle jouer moi
je pense un grand rôle pourquoi parce
que ça irait d'une société ça l'a fait
réfléchir sa partage des valeurs donc
cette pièce de théâtre par exemple et
est un support comme peuvent l'être des
films capucinons avez-vous présenté
votre documentaire à des politiques en
France et quel a été leur réaction
alors j'ai pu le présenter à des
politiques mais c'était plutôt des
politiques sensibles à ces questions là
dans des festivals ce que j'aimerais
juste vous dire c'est que vous verrez
dans dans 10 ans dans 20 ans on trouvera
inadmissible les termes du débat qu'on
avait aujourd'hui pourquoi déjà là on a
évoqué des questions humanitaires et
c'est très bien et on les partage mais
vous pouvez même organiser des arguments
rationnels regarder le patronal allemand
demande des migrants l'Irlande qui a
très peur du vieillissement de sa
population parce que l'Europe vieillit
l'Europe a besoin de bras et vous rendez
compte on laisse les gens s'empaler sur
ces grilles alors que demain on les
réclamera à corps et hakri dans les
usines et je vous assure que le débat
ambiant paraîtra odieux dans 10 ans en
fait il y a une espèce de paralysie sur
les questions d'immigration une peur de
l'opinion et de dire ben on peut
accueillir on peut on peut très bien
délivrer beaucoup plus de visa pour que
beaucoup plus de princes puissent venir
au lieu d'être obligé de prendre de
monter dans des trains d'atterrissage on
peut donner du travail on a voilà Sofia
du coup pour faire le lien selon vous
quelles sont les mesures urgentes que
les États doivent adopter afin de mettre
fin à ses drames
alors
disons que dans les dans le plus urgence
c'est que vous savez aujourd'hui pour
venir en Europe quand on a besoin de
venir soit pour travailler soit parce
qu'on cherche on a besoin d'asile on a
besoin de protection la seule solution
c'est de la seule solution officielle
c'est de demander un visa
et
les visas les états ils en donnent pas
voilà donc la première chose pour
arrêter les drames comme c'est ta
question c'est ça c'est qu'il faut
absolument donner des visas il faut
faciliter la circulation des des pays
entre eux quel message avez-vous lu
faire passer au travers de ce film et à
qui es-tu adressé il est adressé à vous
ce qui aimerait simplement qu'on se
rende compte que Marius le papa de
Laurent Barthélemy c'est un homme comme
comme un Français que Laurent Barthélemy
c'est un être humain aujourd'hui sur
cette petite planète toute bleue et
minuscule il y a deux jours j'étais
encore en lien avec Marius mais ça fait
deux ans et on garde des liens
d'ailleurs je voulais savoir ce qu'il
voulait vous faire passer comme message
parce que ça ça l'intéressait beaucoup
que que des jeunes de votre âge
connaissent l'histoire de son fils donc
à nouveau cette mondialisation elle doit
nous rapprocher et là on voit qu'en ce
moment
on met des herse on met des portes on
met des grilles et on met alors que par
les réseaux sociaux et par le net tout
devrait nous rapprocher donc moi j'ai
pas une vision naïve et idéaliste mais
je dis simplement qu'il faudrait un peu
plus de justice dans ces échanges alors
vous le savez un des extraits de cette
émission seront découpées diffusées sur
les réseaux sociaux ils arriveront
certainement dans des cybercafés de Côte
d'Ivoire et d'ailleurs si
des jeunes là-bas pour garde qu'est-ce
que vous aimeriez leur dire moi les
messages que j'aimerais leur faire
passer c'est surtout le fait qu'ils
aient beaucoup de courage parce que nous
on a vraiment de la chance et leur
routine leur quotidien de vie il faut
vraiment un courage pour le supporter
parce que je sais que moi à leur place
j'aurais vraiment tout quitté j'aurais
risqué la mort pour vivre la vie que je
vis aujourd'hui nous la jeune génération
on réalise de plus en plus qu'il arrive
et on va être là aussi nous aussi pour
les soutenir vraiment il y a des choses
qui vont changer et des choses qui vont
avancer et que leur situation elle va
s'améliorer avec le temps j'aimerais
leur dire qu'il faut pas baisser les
bras il faut continuer de rêver et que
malgré le fait qu'on se connaisse pas
mais on les soutient quand même on va
terminer là-dessus merci merci
infiniment à vous deux Thierry Leclerc
et éclair Rodier d'avoir pris du temps
pour répondre à toutes ces questions
merci infiniment à vous les élèves
voient vous pouvez vous applaudir bravo
pour vos questions bravo pour vos
réflexions on te remercie aussi vos
professeurs qui sont juste là-bas
derrière professeur d'histoire-géo et
professeur des ces bravo bravo à vous
les profs c'est grâce à vous que ce
programme a pu se mettre en place et
puis si vous aussi prof ou élève vous
avez envie de participer à Z et bien
n'hésitez pas écrivez-nous et en
attendant Zed revient très vite avec une
nouvelle classe et un nouveau
documentaire parce qu'il n'y a pas d'âge
pour questionner le monde et ces images
allez salut les élèves
ouais bravo bravo encore merci et
[Musique]